[Music]
on this thursday night get ready canada
an election is about to be called
when will vote we may not know the final
results of the election on election
night the liberals who think this is a
bad idea plus is a campaign during the
fourth wave safe there could be
more transmission of kovit as a result
of the election the third dose the u.s
is on the verge of approving the booster
shot
plus a long life of taking it nice and
slow the milestone for nova scotia's
revered reptile
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us there was always the threat of a
federal election now it's very real
global news can confirm that the liberal
government will call for a vote on
september 20th let's bring in our ottawa
bureau chief mercedes stevenson mercedes
there has been so much speculation about
this election why is justin trudeau
calling it now and how will the process
unfold
well robin on sunday morning prime
minister justin trudeau will walk across
the grounds at rideau hall to ask mary
simon the new governor general to
dissolve parliament triggering the 2021
federal election constitutional experts
say that the governor general will grant
trudeau's request that's because there
has not been an election in recent
months and no other party is trying to
form government the campaign will be 36
days the shortest time allowed under
federal law that puts election day on
monday september 20th and while this is
a snap election it's hardly a surprise
the prime minister had openly stated
2021 would be an election year even
while denying that it would be his party
that would trigger canadians going to
the polls the prime minister's decision
to launch a campaign means he has
decided now is the liberal's best chance
of getting a majority justin trudeau had
to run a political calculation here go
now and risk voter's wrath for
triggering an election in a fourth wave
and when covid 19 numbers are growing
but the liberals have good and not great
numbers or weight and potentially lose
control of the narrative handing timing
of the election to the opposition and
running the risk of the public mood and
economy souring the liberals will likely
frame this campaign as needing to seek a
mandate from canadians to spend more
money and manage the challenges that
they will argue were unforeseen in a
pre-pandemic world
is there any sense mercedes that uh what
the liberals will focus on and is
everyone on board in that party with
calling an election
so while we haven't seen the liberal
platform we can take a few things that
we know from recent spending
announcements the spring budget and the
decision to go to an election now child
care and social programs will likely
feature prominently but the ballot box
question the liberals want is who
canadians trust to govern through the
pandemic and an endorsement for their
pandemic recovery plans typically going
to the polls during a time of crisis
favors the incumbent but some senior
liberals are worried about potential
voter blowback this will be a
hard-fought election no matter what
robin with about a dozen key ridings
where only one to two points could
decide racists getting out the vote will
matter but starting on sunday the prime
minister will have to answer the
question of why this is in canadians
interests and not just the liberal
parties robin mercedes stevenson in
ottawa thanks mercedes
the fourth place party in the house of
commons took the first shot at getting
its ideas to voters jug meet singh
launched a 115-page policy document
today laying out the framework for what
new democrats will campaign on once the
writ drops abigail beeman breaks down
what's new and what's deja vu
we are committed to making them better
for people for workers jagmeet singh
dropped the heart of his party's future
platform in the place where he spent
part of his childhood newfoundland and
labrador that's the vision that we have
for canada making the ultra rich pay
their fair share so we can invest in
people there is a lot packed into the
115 page plan but a lot is not new singh
campaigned on national pharmacare and
dental care more affordable housing and
a wealth tax in 2019 too his party lost
15 seats
but that was before the pandemic that's
what we're hoping people realize that
all the things we talked about are the
things that people need now more than
ever the key challenge for the nep is
that even though you have a similar
package or similar measures or things
that people may have heard before
you have to repackage it and sell it in
the context of a post pandemic recovery
this time around the call for more taxes
goes further there's a repeat of the two
percentage point boost for top bracket
earners to 35 percent now the one
percent wealth tax for the ultra-rich
applies to anyone who earns 10 million
dollars down from 20 and a new coven 19
profit tax would slap a 15 percent tax
on corporations with pandemic windfalls
what we know from public domain polling
is the wealth tax is incredibly popular
the action plan does have new ideas some
triggered by the pandemic including a
call to end for-profit long-term care
and bring in national standards frankly
you know it should be a key election
issue for everyone given the fact that
you know we lost 14 000 residents in
long-term care in those first two waves
alone
so much packed into a pre-platform
document but there is something
noticeably missing clear costing for
many very big promises the party says
that will come in an eventual campaign
and jagmeet singh had some non-policy
news to announce as well thursday he and
his wife are expecting their first child
robin abigail damon in ottawa thanks
abigail
canada is headed into an election just
as canada's top doctor confirms we're in
the fourth wave of the pandemic
nationwide there are now more than 13
000 active infections that's more than
double the number two weeks ago people
aged 20 to 39 make up the majority of
new cases and the number of people
getting severely ill is starting to
climb in the last week patients being
treated in hospital for covet 19 jumped
12
dr theresa tam says the vast majority of
cases and hospitalizations involve
people who are not fully vaccinated
despite the rise she says there are ways
to ensure the election is safe as jamie
morocco reports some public health
experts are skeptical
despite mounting fears about the impact
of a fourth wave canada's top doctor is
confident a federal election is safe
there's a lot that's been learned about
how to make
these kind of
voting spaces if you like
safe elections canada has been preparing
for this possibility for months natasha
gautier told global news part of its top
priority is to deliver an election that
is as safe as possible for voters
for election canada's staff for poll
workers adopting public health measures
such as providing workers with personal
protective equipment masks and face
shields implementing social distancing
guidelines using plastic barriers and
one volunteer per table there will also
be hourly cleaning for voters there will
be hand sanitization stations and a
fresh new miniature pencil for each
person about 16 million of them but mask
requirements will vary province to
province infectious disease specialist
anna banerjee says in alberta which has
eased all covet 19 restrictions
in-person voting stations could lead to
super spreader events unless we're ready
to put back the public health measures
in place and
i think that
there could be
more transmission of covid as a result
of the election then there's the issue
of where to place polling stations
ontario seems torn while manitoba's
premier said schools will be off limits
in his province dr banerjee agrees right
now we're trying to bring the kids back
in school do we want a whole bunch of
adults being in the school
during a fourth wave experts say mail-in
ballots may become the safest and most
popular option elections canada
anticipates 5 million people will vote
this way versus just 54 000 in 2019. we
may not know
the final results of the election on
election night in newfoundland a
labrador spring vote counting mail-in
ballots led to results being delayed
days
finally candidates will also have to get
used to new forms of canvassing in saint
john's thursday ndp leader jagmeet singh
highlighted what experts hope covid
campaigning won't look like maskless
while making close contact with groups
of people
instead parties will need to find new
ways to win over voters ones that keep
everyone safe jimmy marcher global news
toronto
the bc government is making coven 19
vaccines mandatory for long-term care
workers that province's top doctor says
the move is needed to help protect
against highly transmissible new
variants
even when resident immunization is high
as it is across the board in facilities
in this province we have seen
transmission from unvaccinated staff and
it has reinforced and reinforced the
need for protection
henry says workers must be fully
vaccinated by october 12th the new order
also applies to volunteers and personal
service providers who go into long-term
care homes as of today they cannot enter
the homes if they're not vaccinated
the list of canadian universities
requiring vaccines on campus is growing
longer by the day today carlton queens
and the university of guelph in ontario
became the latest schools to announce
that all staff and students must be
vaccinated against kova 19 to be on
campus this fall
one school bucking the trend is the
university of calgary it's encouraging
staff and students to get the shot but
says vaccines and masks will not be
mandatory on campus
anyone hoping to go to a winnipeg jets
home game this coming season must be
fully vaccinated and wear a mask the
team's parent company says the rules
apply to arena employees staff and fans
for now children who don't qualify for
covet 19 vaccines will be allowed to
attend but they'll have to put on a mask
canada is once again being hit hard by
summer heat nearly 15 million canadians
are under heat warnings parts of
newfoundland and labrador and all of new
brunswick nova scotia and prince edward
island are dealing with scorching
temperatures in southern ontario and
quebec hot and humid conditions could
make it feel like 40 degrees and on the
west coast british columbia is baking
the province is in its third heat wave
this summer
today is expected to be the hottest day
of bc's heat wave and there's concern
the potentially record-breaking
temperatures could lead to more
heat-related illnesses and deaths
jennifer palma joins us now from a
popular vancouver beach jennifer
robin all day we've seen british
columbians just trying to beat the heat
right now their focus is just to try and
survive it we're going to wear
air-conditioned hotel room officials
recommend doing errands and activities
before 10 in the morning or after four
to beat the heat and for summer fun at
vancouver's beaches tennis and
volleyball games got underway early as
people walked and rolled to stay cool i
bought a portable air conditioner for my
home it doesn't bother me so much i'm
from australia i just stayed in my
parents air-conditioned room all day we
love lemonade stands we did it yesterday
and we're gonna do another one today the
oppressive heat doe that sat over bc in
june left a grim reminder of how serious
and deadly extreme he can be bc saw
569 heat-related deaths many of them
elderly residents living alone and long
wait times for emergency calls here in a
region where few homes have air
conditioning this time emergency health
workers are deployed where they're most
needed and hospital managers are working
in emergency rooms to help out emergency
management bc is opening cooling centers
and offering transportation to access
them and there are more emergency phone
operators to handle increased call
volumes through the weekend health
officials are concerned about this heat
been through this
twice now in terms of these alerts
coming cooling centers are available the
awareness has been raised
our hope is that we do not see the same
type of uh
mortality and morbidity that is
associated with uh heat events like this
and for those who want to cool down but
aren't sure how in vancouver cooling
centers and misting stations have been
set up to help keep everyone safe the
heat a particular concern for those
living on the streets we are heading out
into alleys into the community we're
handing out water bottles
we're handing out cold water hats
sunscreen lip balm
these survival items that folks need to
endure this heat officials are also
reminding parents and pet owners to not
leave children or pets in cars and to
check on seniors and those who may need
extra help
the peak of the heat is here and while
the next few days might be a little bit
cooler there's still going to be
scorchers and the heat is expected to
last throughout the weekend robin
jennifer palmer in vancouver thanks jen
stifling heat has a grip on much of
southern europe the italian health
ministry has issued warnings about high
temperatures and humidities for at least
15 cities including rome cooling
stations have been set up near popular
tourist sites in the capital in sicily
authorities say the mercury climbed to
48.8 degrees celsius close to the city
of syracuse it's the highest temperature
ever officially documented in europe but
the world meteorological organization
must validate it to become an official
record
those high temperatures continue to
drive deadly wildfires mainly in the
southern regions of sicily and calabria
long spells of drought are also being
blamed officials say the fires are now
under control but at least four people
have died
the speed at which the taliban is
advancing toward afghanistan's capital
is stoking criticism about the u.s
decision to withdraw its troops the last
of which are set to leave by the end of
the month tonight there are reports the
taliban has now taken kandahar earlier
the taliban seized two key cities herat
the third largest city and ganzi which
is about 130 kilometers away from kabul
the u.s is encouraging its citizens to
leave the country and has reduced staff
at its embassy to record diplomatic
presence the department of defense is
moving more personnel to the airport in
kabul to help get embassy staff out
we expect to draw down to a core
diplomatic presence in afghanistan in
the coming weeks
let me be very clear about this the
embassy remains open and we plan to
continue our diplomatic work in
afghanistan
the taliban has now taken over 12
provincial capitals in less than a week
government forces are withdrawing moving
to protect kabul but there are mounting
fears militants will storm and take over
the capital
no more second thoughts about giving out
third shots coming up why the u.s is now
approving another covid19 vaccine dose
plus freezer turn the pilot who landed
in trouble to get ice cream
regulators in the united states are set
to approve cova 19 booster shots for
some people with immune system disorders
research suggests two doses may not be
enough to protect certain
immunocompromised groups and with the
delta variant circulating a third shot
is now recommended as jackson proskow
reports the same could soon be in store
for the general public in both the u.s
and canada
with hospitals once again stretched to
capacity and with a growing body of
research into the contagiousness of the
delta variant the u.s is moving to
recommend an extra dose of vaccine for
those with compromised immune systems
we've been working to identify how best
to provide increased protection to these
vulnerable people who are
disproportionately impacted by severe
outcomes due to carbon 19. a recently
published study by researchers in
toronto found a third dose given to
organ transplant recipients was the best
way to increase protection in those who
may not develop an immune response after
two doses canada is studying whether to
formally approve the practice as well we
will look at the immunocompromised group
separately
from the general population booster
shots are a complicated issue an
estimated one million americans have
already decided to self-medicate and
have lied about vaccination status in
order to receive an unauthorized extra
shot dr anthony fauci believes it's only
a matter of time until boosters are in
fact recommended for everyone we believe
sooner or later you will need a booster
for durability of protection the concern
is the vaccines may lose their potency
over time or may not be as effective
against the delta variant but as the
gulf between vaccinated and unvaccinated
nations grows wider the world health
organization has called for a pause on
boosters we cannot and we should not
accept countries that have already used
most of the global supply of vaccines
using even more of it
epidemiologists agree believing the
better way to control the pandemic is to
reach as many unvaccinated people as
possible first it makes a lot more sense
it benefits everyone much more to really
drive down the numbers overall that are
susceptible to infection those pleas may
not stop the trend toward boosters with
the u.s and other wealthy nations
already holding potential future doses
in reserve
jackson prosco global news washington
to mandate or not to mandate still ahead
the vaccination question facing
employers in a fourth wave
rather than waiting for politicians to
take the lead a growing number of
workplaces across north america have
announced vaccination mandates and
gaviola explains why more canadian
companies and organizations are
increasingly taking matters into their
own hands
this toronto-based firm requires
employees who come into the office or
attend work events to provide proof of
vaccination looking at the broader
context of of the pandemic and now the
delta variant
we really felt that the first and first
thing that we had an obligation to do
was protect our entire team the human
resources department manages the
vaccination policy ensuring privacy and
making accommodations for those who
haven't gotten their jobs
the number of employers across canada
requiring proof of vaccination is
growing and includes several
post-secondary institutions mortgage
platform pinch financial as well as a
handful of bay street law and accounting
firms
[Applause]
the winnipeg jets just announced that
its home games will be sold to full
capacity and all employees event staff
and guests must provide proof of full
vaccination the federal government
announced a digital vaccine program
designed for international travel set to
be available in the fall and quebec is
going ahead with its vaccine passport
set to go live september 1st but leaders
in ontario and alberta have said they're
not going down that route even if a
province decides not to go down the
route of having a vaccine passport it's
critical that they still provide the
infrastructure and the tools for
businesses who do want to have them for
their specific business operation
with so much regional uncertainty thrown
into the mix and medical experts warning
about the dangers of the fourth wave
legal experts say it's clear why private
companies aren't waiting for politicians
to act there's been a shift in the
landscape in terms of not only the
public viewpoint on vaccine certificates
but also i would suggest the legal
viewpoint as well
earlier in the pandemic requiring proof
of vaccination was viewed as the riskier
prospect legally but now the calculation
has changed it's unfortunate that it's
left a private sector to lead the way
and i and i would really encourage our
politicians to to take a look at these
things and
and lead and lead with courage and
sometimes these decisions are hard to
make ann gaviola global news toronto
celebrating the longest living gopher
tortoise up next gus comes out of his
shell for his birthday
if you get regular exercise have a
controlled diet and are loved by
millions it's pretty much the recipe for
longevity for anyone
some words of wisdom on the 99th
birthday of gus the gopher tortoise he's
a living legend at the nova scotia
museum of natural history born and
raised in florida gus has called the
museum home since 1942.
due to the pandemic there's not a big
party this year but in 2022 when gus
turns a hundred the museum is planning a
party for the ages
what would you do for an ice cream cake
well a saskatchewan man's trip to a
dairy queen ended with a criminal charge
this helicopter was seen landing in a
busy parking lot in tisdale people were
shocked to see a man exit the chopper
enter the dairy queen and leave with a
cake police have charged the 34 old
pilot with one count of dangerous
operation of an aircraft oh boy and that
is global national for this thursday
night i'm robin gill tonight your canada
is a national historic site the halifax
public gardens founded in 1836. if you'd
like to share your favorite part of this
vast country please send your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]